[MUSIC]
All right, so
we talked about crowdsourcing,
complaints, disasters.
And I just mentioned
earlier it ultimately comes
down to politics.
And so this talk is going to
analyze the Indian political
process.
>> Well, a small part of it.
Thank you Amed and [INAUDIBLE]
for inviting me here.
So I'm the Ashoka University,
it's a relatively new
University near Delhi.
Where I co-direct a center
called Trivedi Center for
Political Data.
It's named after
Ashok Trivedi an early donor,
who gave us money to fund
the center for ten years.
And we also have one of
my students is here,
Saloni from Ashoka is here.
So I'm presenting the work
of many many students and
other faculty members and staff.
So the center was started in
2016 by a couple of us from
computer science and
political science, so
it's a joint venture.
I think it really worked very
well because when we started,
I mean I didn't know
anything about politics.
I think the political science
people didn't know much about
data management, but we've
learned a lot from each other.
So in that sense it's
been quite successful.
The mission is to understand
Indian political processes and
governmental processes
better through data.
So one of our common TCs was
that there isn't enough informed
discourse in India.
So people would have a certain
theory about what's happening to
cost equations or
what is happening to gender and
so on across India.
But even for something as
basic as a political process,
there isn't good hard data that
you can base open end support.
So we want to enable data
driven discourse through data.
Part of this is of course
doing research ourselves.
Part of it is organizing data
sets and providing them for
journalists, for
students, researchers,
whoever is interested in it and
disseminating that information.
So this is all sort
of properly gathered,
somewhat teacher
quality check data.
We are, of course,
strictly non-partisan and
we have a research orientation,
we collaborate with
several universities,
typically in political
science across the world.
We have 7 staff, about 20
students like I mentioned, and
we're hiring, so if you have
students, post docs, people
interested in this general
space do refer them to us.
So I'll talk about a couple of
projects today the first one is
called Lok Dhaba, it's a play
on Log Server obviously.
This is a data set that you
can look at right now on our
website.
But what we have done is
essentially calculated
Indian elections data
going back to 1962.
And for all the states and
central elections until then
we have gathered data,
integrated it and
made it easy to visualize,
download, and so on.
So this is one place where you
can find information about
everyone who has contested in
election at the central or
at the state level, we don't
go to the local level yet.
So much of this data
actually is available of
the Election Commission's
website,
however it's not in formats
that are easy to consume.
So for example, you would have
PDF files all over the place,
they'll be hiding
inconsistently organized or
inconsistently formatted.
They won't be in a way that you
can actually perform analysis
on them.
So we are trying to
solve that problem.
There is no data quality
checking like I said.
So they have legacy data which
they have collected over
the ages but they really go back
and look at previous elections.
So, one of the distinguished
fellows we have at this center
is Doctor S.Y.
Quraishi the former Chief
Election Commissioner for India.
So he has been very supportive
and helps to educate us about
what the processes inside
the election commission are, and
what the constraints and
capabilities are.
So we have taken this data and
we have made it available
in this interface.
So just like you might
see on a news channel
during elections, you can
generate your own graphs and
maps of how various parties did.
What was the turnout in
various constituencies?
What was the gender ratio?
Things like that.
But you can ask this for any
election going back to 1962 and
you can sort of build
your own visualization.
So these are some maps, there
are some graphs, and so on.
But behind it all is a lot of
systematic quality checking of
the data.
So for a example, when we put
together all the election
commission data, we find that
they are inconsistencies like
same party, same election,
same constituency.
You have multiple people from
the same party which is not
possible, right?
So they have some data
entry errors somewhere or
they have some problem
in the process.
Inconsistent constituency type,
like constituency divided in
India according to gender SC or
SD within the limitations
that the type is not
supposed to change.
But we find cases where they do
change, so these are a bunch of
checks that our political
scientists thought of or
we thought of and
included on this spreadsheet.
So now that you have
a database of sorts,
it's not actually
a very big database,
in the sense of big data, it's
only about two million rows.
So we're talking of all
candidates who ever contested,
not just the winners.
Everyone who's ever contested
an election at the state or
the central level.
So we load down these old
consistency checks to write and
then we find these problems,
we refer them back to the
election commission and so on.
We also try to integrate
different sources, so
things like whoever the election
commission deems to be a winner
should correlate with whoever
ends up in local server, right?
But we find that the Lok Sabha
record actually says something
different, mostly its
a Lok Sabha problem,
actually the election
commission is relatively clean,
data is relatively clean.
But the Lok server has various
gotchas, various problems,
sometimes there are processes
we don't know about or
that are very kind of
mysterious or unknown process.
Particularly in the earlier
years, so for example, and
the reason we don't go beyond
1962 is that before then there
were actually multiple winners
per seat, in some cases.
Because some seats had special
members for special casts or
even in some cases for
certain communities.
So it gets very very messy
before then but after 1962,
it is relatively clean.
So I'll come back to this later
when I mention the kind of
work that computer science
research can enable over here.
So this is
the Lok Sabha website.
And the general problem is
given one data source and
another data source how
do you map entries that
are mostly similar and
integrated that way?
Another big problem is there
isn't a single identifier for
a person in
the political process.
So if you have even who was
contested in one election and
in the next, you don't know
if that is the same person or
not because it could be
a relatively common name.
And the number of people with
very common names especially in
states like Punjab and
is not funny.
So because of this
political scientists
can't ask questions that they're
very interested like what is
happening with respect
to incumbency over time?
Are there more people entering
the political process or less?
How long do they stay on
average and things like that.
What are the trends along age,
cast, gender, region?
What are the differences
there and so on.
So we've built what's
essentially an entity
resolution tool to help map
people who are the same
across different elections.
And I'll skip
through it quickly.
Basically, if you look at the
literature entity resolution is
kind of a solved problem,
but when you look for
a tool that you can actually
give political scientists that
they can use, there aren't many.
So we have built a tool that
factors in approximate Indian
name matching to help
resolve these rows and so on.
So if you're interested come
talk to me later about it.
I want to mention a second
project we did in the context of
Smart Cities with the city
of Hubballi-Dharwad in north
Karnataka.
It so
happens that I lived there and
I had some connections
to the city.
And so when the Smart City
proposals were being worked out
a couple of years ago,
I told them that ever other
city was having a marathon, and
a workathon, and all of that.
I said we'll have a hackathon.
And so, because everyone
was interested in preparing
the Smart City proposal, they
gladly gave a lot of data to us,
which was very interesting.
So we of course, we told
them about 5-Star Open Data,
which [INAUDIBLE] has
been talking about.
One star is when you
just put the data out,
make it available without
the need for RTis and
things like that to linked
open data which is 5-star and
then it's integratable with
other data sources and so on.
So a couple of my
students built this app,
it's a site called hdworks.org,
you can go and check it.
Basically what it is it's a list
of all spending by the city,
which is of course it's supposed
to be all public and RTI-able,
except it's not
actually consumable and
usable by most people.
So you can in this case for
the city of Hubballi-Dharwad,
you can look over all the works.
You can see who's contractor,
what's the source of funding,
what's the amount and so on.
We have provided ways that you
can geotag, you can say this
work was done on this road and
this much money was spent on it.
You can have officials upload
pictures of the work that was
done, so the officials will say
yeah this money was sanctioned
for the road, that's the road.
But there is also a way for
citizens to give feedback and
then the citizens will tell you
that the road is actually
something like this.
>> [LAUGH]
>> So
this is very useful for actually
the municipal commissioner to
look at what's happening
across the city.
So that's what we're
trying to enable and
trying to study
crowd-sourcing and
citizen involvement
in that context.
We have sort of
standing queries, so
you can subscribe to a certain
work or a certain ward.
And get information when
there is an update about work
happening in that ward and
so on.
So I see I am out of time and
I'm going to skip to this last
part to, I'll just take half
a minute to mention computer
science problems in particular.
So, easing data collection and
analysis from loosely
structured sources, whether
it's web or other sources, it's
a long-standing problem with
something that we experienced
painfully over the last
couple of years.
Automatic generation of
data quality checks so
I mentioned a few data quality
checks that we thought about and
enforced on
the election data set.
But what if you could have tools
that sort of do data mining and
online detection and
things like that, and
figure out that this is a likely
check that two people from
the same party can't contest in
same election, in the same year,
in the same constituency.
Can you join similar columns?
Like I have
a Lok Sabha data set,
I have an election
commission data set,
they are mostly the same but
there are differences whether
it's in spelling, or
for other reasons.
Can I have a loose join,
an interactive join where I can
say 90% of your data is okay,
5% is okay, modular spelling
corrections and so on.
5% is something you
need to look at,
this is something that Soloni
for example spent a month on and
can we automate this process?
Can you have conversational
interfaces, data?
So it seems like we can talk to
your phones, we can talk to our
rooms and so on with Siri and
things like that.
Can you instead have
political scientists or
others talking to data
centers in natural language?
Can express these whether
its quantity checks or
queries in natural language?
Okay and we are doing
a bunch of work on user
interfaces and so on.
So let's skip that, you can
contact me later if you have
questions and also here today
and tomorrow, thank you.
>> [APPLAUSE]